welcome welcome welcome ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls kids of all
ages to Startalk radio
bill nighy here sitting in for Neil
deGrasse Tyson and I'm here today with
none other than Chuck nice hey Bill and
we are going to have cosmic queries yes
we are questions from the cosmos
submitted by you to Chuck and Chuck you
not only have the questions you have
what they want to look like that's right
I do what they want to look like it
because these are their avatars from
Facebook and Twitter and what have you
and we have questions from all over the
internet wherever we find a home and
before you go any cut just want to point
out that we are excited to have GE is a
partner for this inaugural video cosmic
queries head over to their YouTube page
to check out videos of how they are
bringing imagination to life I'm talking
about ww2 calm yes we have a query yes
we do let's jump right into this and go
to Justin Connors who's coming to us via
Facebook and Justin says this since Mars
core cooled off much faster than Earth
because of its higher surface area
wouldn't it have had a much earlier
start than that of Earth that is to say
how much sooner could Mars have been
habitable than Earth also what kind of
period of time could Mars have had to
develop and sustain life and could you
compare that to earth so so it can we
first of all this is a fabulous quote it
is a great question and let me say he
worded it as best as he could but it's
that it's not just that Mars has it's
not that Mars has more surface area it
has more surface area relative to its
mass it's a smaller thing it has about
as much surface area as the land of the
earth the dry land of the earth okay and
so the number that I hear people work
with quite a bit for Mars is four
billion years ago it would have cooled
off enough to have liquid water
running around on Mars okay so that
would be pick a number a billion or half
a billion years before the earth so
maybe it is just not it's not crazy but
it's extraordinary to say that life
started on Mars Mars was hit with an
impact or about three billion years ago
stuff got tossed off into space through
home and orbits a little mathematical
fabulous thing these rocks with living
things and I'm landed on earth and you
and I are descendants from from those
particular microbes so we are really
Martians it could possible it could be
but I'll tell you what tell you what it
is it is worth finding out it is worth
mounting a human mission to Mars to go
look for signs of water in life that's
if we were to discover evidence of life
on Mars on that other world it would
utterly change this one in the same way
astronomy has humbled us through the
ages right we found out that we go
around the Sun not the other way around
right we find out that planets are if I
made a dime a dozen maybe even cheaper
than that maybe and so we are no big
deal our star is nobody our Sun is no
big deal star wise and maybe life
happens all the time and is worth
knowing as they say your world is
getting smaller and smaller and you
didn't even know it I didn't write this
joke it's a good one go ahead it may be
a small world but I wouldn't want to
have to paint it so okay that's really
actually a great question and pretty
fascinating stuff let me ask you about
the Mars rover though as an addendum to
this question Curiosity rover the
Curiosity as there's an opportunity
spirit and Sojourner but right now we've
got opportunity running and curiosity I
take it okay so have they been able to
determine whether or not there's been
any not life of course but rivers
streams things of that nature
what place used to be very wet okay and
the Curiosity rover landed in
essentially a stream bed that's crazy
you see these rocks embedded in what was
ancient mud that solidified into rock
and and then opportun
dirty stumbled or rolled up to a layer
of gypsum this is the rock that looks
that you make wallboard out of right and
it is a mineral that only shows up when
things are really wet by Clay's and so
geologists you know they just can't get
enough to go crazy their minds what we
want to do is go to someplace if I may
even more interesting but to get to such
an interesting place you have to be able
to land more accurately the places we
land these Rovers are wide open spaces
of course we can not crash very much
right yeah cuz those are some expensive
stuff with let me tell you something
okay opportunity curiosity gather about
three and a half billion dollars right
spirit they're not even locked okay
anybody could just walk up to those
Rovers that's weird
we left up there with the big walls are
in them is it now yes they're virtually
bait cars is what they are I'm saying
they're like virtually bait surprise the
wheels are still on them after all this
time alright let's move on
here's another one from Scott Scott
wants to know oh sorry sorry no Scott
Scott you're going sorry I'm not doing
Scott I'm doing Doug McKenzie Doug and
Doug wants to know this I understand
Doppler effect with sound mmm
but give light speed properties how does
it catch up or pull away from itself to
create red and blue chips oh it's
fabulous so here's the cool thing
another good question it's a fabulous
question this is the great thing to
grasp about the Doppler effect and by
the way full disclosure my brother still
dreams of starting a band called
Christian Doppler and the effects but
his first name is not Christian so oh
well anyway that aside spike who Deanna
Blowfish yes that's right
Darius Rucker is actually Hootie so tell
your brother he could do that yet he's
it's totally fine it's crazy
okay what this said here's the thing to
grasp is the frequency is what changes
not the speed ah so it's a it's a
fabulous subtle thing when we do
experiments on light to observe waves we
observe waves right and when
if you can show or accept that sound
travels and waves then you can by
perfect analogy you have light
travelling waves and get the right
answer so as an object like a star moves
away from us at extraordinary speeds
dozens and hundreds of kilometers a
second it stretches the waves of light
and so they go to lower frequencies and
it's you have trouble remembering this I
strongly encourage you just to do a
little Latin Ultra means beyond ultra
violet is beyond violet infra means
below in fries below red so the red is
the longer wavelength and blue and
violet are the shorter wavelengths so
when you go faster and faster away your
wavelength is stretched out the speed of
lights the same the wavelength is
stretched out and so the color as we
perceive it the color changes fabulous
question that is really fantastic laws
that's where we get what Ultraman
that's right ultra moans remain miss B
on man blinking light stops that's right
I remind you
Ultraman may never rise again hi Jana
and the science Patrol Chuck and I will
be back right after this
welcome back to start talk radio Bill
Nighy guest hosting for our beloved Neil
deGrasse Tyson I am here with Chuck nice
that's right
and you know what's cool Chuck what slow
mo even cooler super slow-mo head over
to GES YouTube channel and get a look at
what gzip - with their super hydrophobic
materials and watch what it looks like
when a t-1000 gets built that's right WW
youtube.com slash GE that's it ladies
and gentlemen that's it with that said
before the break Chuck and I got off on
a little ultraman tangent yessir man for
those of you unfamiliar it's a japanese
superhero yes and that he was Japanese
was a big part of it yes it was because
he was fluent in karate
he was giant guy it was a giant on the
science of science patrol he would Ohio
des was his civilian name like our Clark
Kent correct takes out his beta capsule
correct he would become Ultraman and
some reason Ultraman had a light that
flashed on his chest and it was pre
every week Chuck there's a monster every
week there was a monster and just and
from somewhere from some the bottom of
the sea somewhere a mild with him here
yes an Ultraman had to be called it's
very stressful and it shows you
something about our deepest fears that
the unknown and monsters are trouble and
I got to think it's related to the
Japanese islands tendency to have
earthquakes I thought it was the fact
that we dropped a bomb on them that was
a hundred million megatons I was about
30 carry time very hot and so I think
this the monster thing goes back in
Japanese culture way before it way
before and can I name the artist you
dropped a bomb on me was it you dropped
a bomb on me and then you'd hear the
bombing I want to say cool in the game
no no no oh yeah we got it we got
working oh yeah yeah up my tongue gap
fan gap band you dropped a bomb on me
okay here we go with that another
question
a cosmic query actually
and just think what it was like
conducting warfare without aircraft now
we can't imagine it and the whole world
as of this broadcast the whole world is
fascinated with whatever became of
Malaysia flight 370 absolutely our
fascination with flying is deep within
us and spaceflight is perhaps the
ultimate expression of flying I would
agree all right let's let's take one
from Saeed who wants to know this all
right say aside at his rest last name is
Russian side Russian wants to know this
will the earth ever increase or decrease
in its size over life over its life over
its life not out well I got to think
yeah now geologists I'm sure have
pondered this question deeply it's a
question of tight timing time timing
will the Sun expand and heat the earth
before the earth has a chance to cool
off see when you cool the metal of the
inside of the earth your nickel your
iron your molten earth core right are
you going to you're going to shrink but
will the Sun come out here and hook and
cook things up before that have I think
the Sun is going to beat us as far as
cooling the earth off I wouldn't worry
about it and let me remind you one of
the tremendous insights into the nature
of geology the nature of our place in
space people wondered quite reasonably
how could you have evolution happen over
three billion years how could the earth
stay hot as it seems to have all this
time and you can tell the Earth's hot
and so when you have a volcano
absolutely which we have now and then
that and the way Venus looks at us lets
us know we're hot I'm sorry oh I'm sure
you're right Chuck I'm sure you're right
I've always kind of had a thing for
Venus myself I don't blame you but that
said uh Venus stays really hot for other
reasons anyway the inside of the earth
has fishing going on nuclear fission and
that keeps it really hot but eventually
you would think hypothetically
theoretically things would cool off but
I think the sun's going to heat up and
cook us before then
stays hot because of all its carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere which is run
away with the greenhouse effect so Venus
please could could that be our future is
what will you talk about the greenhouse
effect it's could it be no I don't think
so Venus is so hot how hot is thank you
it's so hot that the ground that you
would melt LED on the ground you take
your fishing weights but it would melt
on your stainless steel cutlery would
just just Bend yield so furthermore it's
Salvador Dali painting it would be
really but you'd be dead too before he
could appreciate it
probably I mean instantly and then
furthermore it not only the wait wait
there's more
it rains acid rain Wow
environmental disaster this place is
like hell and the guys who did the first
in the modern era not the people from
the 1700s in the early eighteen or
nineteen hundred in the modern era the
people who discovered climate change on
earth Michael Mann to a lesser extent
but Jim had James Hansen okay June of
1980 1983 all right testified in front
of Congress it was it was studying Venus
the atmosphere of Venus with telescopes
that people discovered the real the real
various effects it all have too much how
I saw too much carbon arcs Wow Wow and
by too much we're talking about just a
little bit too much just a little just a
little bit and that's all we need here
it's just a little bit right and it's
game over
yes but I think it's gonna happen even
if I whisper bad Chuck we have another
query I just oh yeah
you know I'm laughing because we do have
a tendency to do that when something's
bad Trevor see the whisper like that
make it okay but I remind you the earth
can still hear you
we're now over 400 bars per million of
carbon dioxide in the air
fan there you go even if you whisper
back it's still gonna happen alright
let's let's move on to Matt Milligan and
this what Matt wants to know why does
the light from stars go on for billions
of light years but the light from my
blast light will only go two feet Oh No
oh it does go up does that good question
but first of all let's remind us the
light years a unit of distance not a
unit not a mean of threat its speed of
light times time and just if you want to
do that gets you the distance if you and
by the way everybody if you're out there
having trouble with your distance equals
rate times time problems just relax just
look at the units if you're going meters
per second times seconds you're gonna
get meters if you're going miles per
hour times hours you're gonna get miles
chair is happy speed of light times
years you get a long way a light year
all right now your flashlight it I used
to sit on the beach particularly well
and sometimes the forest and shoot the
light straight up the flashlight
straight up and wonder if there was
somebody else out there on another
planet to pick one Rigel 12 Rigel 12
who's doing the same thing
here's lovely in the spring by the way
on right it could be with the Rigel
Ian's and is there such a ride Elian out
there shooting her or his flashlight
back at me and yes the photons do go on
forever it's just they get so dim your
eyes can't detect them now in a room
where you shine your light around that
light will get absorbed by your quilt
that's in your bedroom got to even the
paint of your walls is absorbed what if
you set up mirrors everywhere on all the
walls and you turn on the light what a
bounce run forever no even at 99.99999%
at the speed of light things bounce
around very quickly and it's all
observers olives or turned into heat
okay sorry man
we radiated in another form of light but
in general so it's still there it's just
kind of energy and energy doesn't go
away it's going well there it's just
like hey baby this is what I am now
gotcha uh in those terms I might have
been a very scientific I don't that may
have been how the gap band would have
expressed or a people from that era of
that era hey hey baby
I was just something else now I'm just
I'm just an energy man alright let's
move on hmm y-you know we really don't
have to okay
wow this is a question directly for you
okay let me see okay I think we might
have enough time hey Bill Matt here
student at Sacramento State University
California Sac State there you go
when we see an object of light away from
us we are seeing it in a year in the
past Oh an object a light year from us
we're seeing a year in the past okay
reasonable way of record so reasonably
with theoretically if we are able to
grow a tree say five light-years tall
with the aid of a telescope will we be
able to see the different ages of the
tree as we look at its farthest branches
say for example the tree begins to dine
near the ground
bla bla bla so the short answer is no
okay
because you can only see it at the speed
of light in other words you can't detect
that it's dying out there on the end of
its five light-year away branch right
unless you're looking at the light
bouncing off the branch so along this
line another interesting thing to
interestingly think about you say you're
looking at light on distant stars what's
ever happened there has already happened
right be that as it may it hasn't
happened here yet until the light gets
here right and this gets into this thing
of information theory like does it
really
although the thing landed on Mars 11
minutes ago it hasn't landed on Mars
here until the light gets here do do to
to to to to to we will discuss this
further right after this
welcome back to star talk radio Bill
Nighy here guest hosting if I can use
that verb for Neil deGrasse Tyson and
people check me out because I'm with
Chuck nice yes and it is fabulous I
don't think he's gonna change his name
knock of the Tasman it's a fabulous not
too fat but he could no I'm saying now
that sounds too much like a rapper as
you know chug-chug-chug catalyst what
does Chuck nice sound like yeah you know
what oh well that's what it sounds like
young man certainly no nice no one is
afraid of nice that is for sure
and they should be this guy will cut you
it's good though it's good that's Chuck
cosmic queries your queries yes from the
electric interweb the kids are using yes
very happy that you all took the time to
write to us and your questions this show
especially have been just outstanding we
really have had some we another one idea
before we go into the next question very
quickly um I just because we were you
didn't finish this because we had to
come back for the break but we were
talking the break very quickly about I
said I think that we're so science
averse in our country because there's
certain people who benefit from that
because they have it gives them power
some power it gives them power I mean
that's just my own personal opinion and
so this is especially true of military
hardware okay historically this these
scientists have been pressed into
service
you know Galileo I guess franja frother
was pressed into service in science in
the military using science in the
military making these extraordinary
lenses and stuff with that said science
democratizes knowledge and I Chuck yeah
this may mean this more to me than it
should but it doesn't matter who shows
you the earth goes around the Sun the
man does not control who what makes the
earth goes around the Sun science is
true for everybody
true science is is knowledge outside of
us science is as near as we can tell
what we hope to find in science of rules
or laws or thing are ways of looking
things that are true everywhere in the
universe doesn't matter where you're
from your ethnic background how much
money your aunt
Chester's made the man does not control
the facts of science data is an elegant
beautiful thing so you and I and the
regular host Neil deGrasse Tyson are
working to change the world so everybody
listening to the broadcast right now
turn it up loud as we take another
cosmic query fantastic that was
outstanding sir let's move on Jerry it's
he Sandburg wants to know this if you
could bore to the center of the earth
and not get burned to a cinder
let's suspense of disbelief here and how
about a spear in the drum in the
geometric center of the earth
how would gravity affect you then so oh
it's cool there'd be no gravity so so
you'd be 0 G 0 G so what we recommend to
you all is get yourself a drill well
take physics and a classic physics
problem which is every bit as much fun
as what you just described yeah is
drilling a hole a hypothetically
imaginary hole through the center of the
earth and then you big enough for pick
an enchanting object a bowling ball okay
and drop it through the hole in the
center of the earth what happens as you
get as the ball goes all the way through
and then comes out the other side the
other side happens ah does it shoot off
into space
no it falls back walk back through over
and over nowhere with no aerodynamic
drag and rat brain burned to a cinder
right and this is a fabulous problem and
wait wait there's more I'm a mechanical
engineer and as I like to add I'm also
human
I'm mechanical engineer and one of my
really satisfying technical jobs was
working on this navigation system for
drill bits this would be the technology
that is the ancestor of modern fracking
drills no kidding where you can guide
the drill steer it underground okay with
extraordinary precision like when they
had this oil well leak in the Gulf Linda
go ahead come inside ways you can guide
drill bits very accurately and
the moment you start going down inside
the earth there's less gravity wow do
two two two two two two two two two two
and these were detected by our
accelerometers this was at a company
called Sun Strand data control which is
now part of Honeywell and these
accelerometers are excels because we're
so cool these excels would detect micro
G's millionths of a millionth of a G and
so when you have a shell of material
this is a mathematical shell of material
above you right it all cancels out Wow
and so to those of you listening who
have not taken physics and have not
tried this math problem right I
encourage you to do it it's a these are
both just outstanding cool insightful
math problems that would come to us
really from the discoveries made by
Isaac Newton like what where were you
when I was taking physics in school I
don't know man man physics it is off it
is all sciences either physics or stamp
collecting but that turns out that's
from a different era turns out now life
science is so fantastically complicated
it kind of overwhelms physics much as I
love my physics take it sorry I digress
impatient you know what we have a minute
left in this segment so I got Derek
Wilson here who has a really cool
question
I think I know why he's asking this how
accurate is carbon dating really very
accurate and the longer the least long
time ago or it was the better more
accurately it is this is to say when I
was about to say I think he's asking so
here's how it works
is carbon-14 is formed in the air when
you are a living thing and you stop
breathing or stop transpiring if you're
a plant the carbon-14 changes to
nitrogen and then took back then down to
carbon-12 and so the moment you die or
stop breathing this process happens the
carbon-14 doesn't get refreshed and so
it's extraordinarily accurate but do not
confuse carbon-14 dating with how we
determine the age of the ancient
dinosaurs exactly that's potassium argon
and uranium uranium and rubidium
strontium we'll be back after this
welcome back to star talk radio Bill
Nighy here guest hosting for Neil
deGrasse Tyson and wait wait there's
more everybody I'm not here by myself no
no I'm here with Chuck nice that's right
and it's a beautiful it's all that it is
it's so good to have you here Chuck I'm
in we're having a blast what are we
doing today we are taking what cosmic
queries these are queries from the
internet well from the cosmos chart they
are from the cosmos via the internet yes
they are precisely and we have quite a
few people who've actually um written in
to ask specific questions of you bill I
know that people got a lot of free time
out there I know because they're saying
hey Bill you know like will Burke who
wants to know this are there any
locations in the solar system that you
think we should focus more on sending a
mission what benefit would we gain from
doing so well we at the Planetary
Society the world's largest
non-governmental space interest
organization advancing space science and
exploration for the betterment of
humankind where we want everyone on
earth to know the cosmos and our place
within it that Planetary Society
encourages missions to all these worlds
Enceladus moon of Saturn that has it
seems to have an ocean and Europa which
has got an ocean we want to go to Titan
where their tides of methane and ethane
these mmm baby blue natural gas kind of
liquids their liquid because it's a
crazy cold smells like a fragrant trip
uh and we would put sniffers on them by
the way and just to go on as far as just
keep in mind if we were discover
evidence of life on one of these worlds
like Europa or Enceladus or Mars it
would change this world
utterly change this world it would
change the way everybody felt about what
it is to be alive in the universe or
having the cosmos it would change us and
you know what else we'd discover what
nobody knows that's why we're going to
go send missions to find stuff if we
send missions out there we will make
discoveries and we will have an
adventure an adventure shared by all
humankind
if you talk to kids what are they and
you say what
your favorite planet they often not so
much as they used to thanks to me oh
they'll say Pluto that's so true
Pluto thanks folks tell you what 2015
there is a mission going by Pluto New
Horizons it left in 2006 I was there at
Cape Canaveral going that's the fastest
rocket anybody's ever built and we'll
get to Pluto nine years later in 2015
and we will make discoveries that will
change things furthermore when you
invest in these missions Chuck yes you
solve problems that have never been
solved before so true so planetary
science is what NASA does best right now
yeah and NASA's the world's largest
space agency by a factor of 3 so that is
planetary science the line item within
NASA which is internal line item within
the federal budget which is in turn a
economic entity in the world that's
where we invest to innovate and keep the
United States in the economic game next
question
awesome answer sir alright JD Provost
wants to know this if a planet had a
slower axis rotation allowing the star
and its orbiting it that it's orbiting
to heat the planet over a longer day so
bigger planet yeah he'd look could a
planet be further out of what we
consider the habitable zone and still
sustain life at similar temperatures as
Earth so bigger planet farther out
longer day well let's do all those
things factor into let's back up the
earth day used to be before we had
clocks as far as it used to be 18 hours
in the ancient dinosaur days so that's a
fact that's like 30% that the earth is
going 1/3 slower than it used to I did
not know that we're here we're alive so
you got a figure if you're farther out
and turning slowly if conditions are
right you could be a living thing you've
got if why not who's to stop you wait
wait there's more the planet Mercury
spins 2/3 of a time for every orbit and
I don't think there are any mercury ins
because it's too close to the Sun from
what we understand right
but there's ice in the craters of
mercury is there someplace on some other
world that's turning slowly that has
some slush and there's living things in
it I don't know right one way to find to
make sure we never find out is to stay
here not go look and not go looking
exactly wow that is very cool that is
hey hey JD number one a great question
and number two who knew that the Earth
Day used to be a teen hour that's when
you talk to the ancient dinosaurs take a
meeting with them but really they're the
fossil ferns that are extant that are
along with their fossils okay you can
infer a lot about ancient environment
and then you look at silts and ice right
and things and you can infer a lot about
how the earth is slowing down now caused
by tidal friction with the moon and you
can work backwards to how fast it must
have been spinning in ancient times
meanwhile we've got a spin on out to a
break hey Bill Nye here guest hosting
for my beloved my good friend Neil
deGrasse Tyson here on Startalk radio I
don't want you to be jealous
yes I'm here with Chuck nice and he is
all that ladies he is nice now Chuck we
had a question right before the break
yes we did an Artie feely wanted to know
climate climate change deniers drive me
crazy how can we convince them that the
data is real and not some kind of scam
well here's the thing about the scam
conspiracy theories are lazy wouldn't it
be nice if there were someone in charge
screwing things up on purpose but
actually things are screwed up just sort
of by accident we got seven billion
people living on a planet where the
atmosphere is just this big if you could
drive straight up on some crazy road
with some crazy car you'd be in outer
space in an hour and a half the way
people drive in New York you'd be there
and maybe quality five minutes yeah
exactly so conspiracy theories are are
not very good explanations for things
especially something as complicated as
climate change I encourage you to read
the hockey stick by Michael Mann
full disclosure paperback version I
wrote the foreword now Chuck it's time
for the lightning round yes it is you
have the bell there and what we are
going to do is we are going to zip
through these questions as quickly as
possible let me remind you guys this
installment of the lightning round is
powered by our good friends over at GE
you should head over to their YouTube
page and take a quick look at some of
the cool things they're doing quick
right after this segment
ww youtube.com slash GE yeah right let's
move on to the bike look to the
lightning round and there you go let's
start with Rachel Pomeroy at Rachel palm
she wants to know this we know some
things can be ignited with light can
anything be ignited with sound oh yeah
really sure what you get it you get it
vibrating at its natural frequency if
it's something that's gonna fatigue you
ever tried to straighten out a paper
clip and it gets warm take a rubber band
stretches dress your trinkets it gets
hot you can get it hot enough to burn
whoa that was awesome
all right this is at a Corbin bond spot
okay this is Daniel is his name and he
actually sent this to you cuz you're at
Science Guy right mm-hmm okay so he
wants to know at Science Guy here we uh
crap here we go look that's a question
ha ha ha ha I lost I lost the question
oh here we go he actually sent this to
you cuz you're at Science Guy right yes
ok here we go
could we build a space elevator to the
moon's pole from the Earth's Pole a
space elevator a very difficult business
because the moon is going around the
earth it's orbiting although because
even though he's a little vibration if
say it faces the same face to us it's an
eigenvalue if you're scoring along with
us a proper value so it rotates once
well every month so you're going to have
to have a pivot you're going to have to
have something like a Cowboys wrist with
wrist a so
excellent the answer is no yeah yes no
this one is from at one guilty pleasure
also for you this is straight to you
bill um is it possible that dark matter
is the excrement of a black hole he's
being funny but I know what he's asked
yeah it's pretty funny it could be that
what things that fall into a black hole
come out another part of the universe at
another time have they been modified the
things that fall in have vide has the
stuff turned into dark stuff has it
become comprised of dark archons awesome
so the answer is maybe maybe maybe clear
maybe that's right okay let's um let's
go it's lightening chocolate let's go
here we go
this one is from Mark and he wants to
know this can we protect a spaceship
with an artificial magnetic field the
same way it's around our earth
hypothetically people talk about this
quite about quite a bit if you had a
huge power sort by power mean
electricity power source some reactor
with a Stirling engine and a generator
out there on your spacecraft you could
maybe make a magnetic field so powerful
that you would deflect solar the solar
wind and all those particles and cosmic
rays that could maybe like cosmic rays
the things that could cause you trouble
all the radiation could be the radiation
could be deflected around your ship ah
so the answer is yes yes number one
shields up
okay this one from Adam Forrest buckling
see shield for always trouble lead on
this is from at lauralee biology um can
Bill comment on Hawking's new claims
regarding event horizons yeah yeah I
mean it's apparently he's things that
fall into black holes may not come out
at another part of the universe at
another time you may be a way to get the
energy back that's the way I understand
the paper gotcha and she asked can I
comment I did I'm ignorant
fantastic all right this one from @cj
Robinson wants to know this what would
happen to our atmosphere if gravity was
turned off for one minute
so no gravity on earth for one minute
what would the effects be we remind you
inertia is a property of matter so I
guess if we turned off the gravity for a
minute the everything would continue to
spin through space for a while but then
you start getting a lot of outgassing
random collisions the atmosphere would
be warmer than space so those molecules
would bounce off each other and
disappear forever
whoa okay so we're running out of time
we're down to the wire this is from
Scott Avion and he wants to know what
advice can you give a new science
teacher from k-12 trying to really
engage their children enix and get them
excited about sciences oh that's a
fabulous question Chuck what was your
favorite thing about your favorite
teacher uh they made me want to learn
they've made her passionate ass him
they're passionate so guy what's his
name yes Scott Scott let your passion
come through and we'll see you next time
on star talk radio I'm here with Chuck
nice and we have had nothing but fun
thanks for listening